nothing is more important
than the full involvement of women in
decision making in our society whether
it's a governmental education
military corporate america so my message
to young women would be
know your power be confident
and understand that nothing is more
important than you
fulfilling your role whatever that may
be
[Music]
i had no idea that i would run for
public office
i was doing what i love to do being a
mom
and so as that was coming to its
shall we say they were going away to
college and the rest
uh i i was interested in doing something
i just had all this energy and uh
and motivation i i my motivation my
why to do anything sprang from being a
mom because
one in five children in america lives in
poverty goes to sleep hungry at night
so that was really sort of my motivation
women just have to make their decisions
decisions are the most liberating
acts you can make you decide decide i'm
going to
start my family or decide i'm going to
go start my career
and then come back to that it's hard to
do both
at once but it's very possible i have
four
daughters who are professionals they had
their families and their careers at the
same time
but that was their decision
your path is your path don't worry about
following somebody else's path
what it what it will have its own
natural tempo
and it's challenging you know it is
challenging to
to multi-task all the time with family
and the rest
people tell me that's the hardest thing
for them
is how do they allocate their time
[Music]
you don't know what's around the corner
so
just be confident in who you are and
that you have a plan you have a vision
and you have a plan
you will succeed
you